For the first time, the number of new coronavirus cases outside of China...
...has surpassed the new number of cases reported in China,...
...with more than 82,000 cases confirmed worldwide and a global death toll near 2,800.
In Saudi Arabia, the government is suspending foreign visa issuance for the Umrah pilgrimage...
...over coronavirus fears.
Saudi Arabia said the suspensions were temporary,...
...and it is unknown how the decision would affect the annual Hajj.
In India, police marched through the streets of New Delhi...
...to calm the riots that have been occurring the past few days.
Current counts say at least 38 have died as a result of the riots.
Swarms of locusts continue ravishing crops in East Africa...
...as the population increases.
The Food and Agriculture Organization...
...estimated last month that the number of locusts...
...could multiply 500 times by June if left unchecked.
Finally from the US, stocks dropped nearly 1,000 points at opening...
...due to continued fears of the coronavirus epidemic spreading,...
...before rebounding slightly midday.